it's just a quick like six to eight
minutes I'll play this for you and I
want you to hear it out okay
plastic tone might have landed a little
bit a bit funny for him
wow I did not ask you guys advice about
that yeah Adam shut your mouth
hey let's welcome Dawn
hi guys how are ya
yay yes you are what are you doing here
um well my boyfriend Paul's been like
really silly lately and he's avoiding me
so it's kind of getting annoying and I
just like want this little game that
he's playing to be over it's not funny
anymore silly okay silly goose so
you're just for clarity the guy's not
responding to her text messages or calls
and he's basically ghost sitter and
she's calling into the radio station
because she's familiar with the segment
and this happens every time because she
wants them to call him to find out
what's up and basically put him on the
spot on the radio in front of
essentially her world
so tell us a little bit about your
history then
um like uh how long you've been dating
uh you know when did he stop talking to
you that sort of stuff
um we've been dating for like three
months and stuff
um you know like we push each other's
buttons from time to time it never
really lasts long but like right now I
haven't heard from him in four days okay
let me just deal with the push each
other's buttons thing but it never lasts
very long
what she's talking about is fighting
okay
um the first several months of dating a
girl should be like a honeymoon it
should be smooth it should be fun it
should be lots of agreeableness sort of
thing but the way that she's describing
it right away is that there's an
insufferable conflict that goes on
between them she's not saying it yet but
you're about to hear it so let's keep
going
it's just it's dumb it's enough and we
need to like
figure out what's going on okay okay
four days and no no argument or anything
um like that's
that's just part of our Dynamic you know
um listen let me just be clear here guys
arguing should not be part of your
Dynamic when it comes to a relationship
on any basis okay I know that there's
people out there who tell you oh there's
you know there's always going to be
conflict but constant bickering and
arguing amongst yourselves if it's
happening within three months this is
like a run forest run this is get the
hell out of there
can we just call him now okay sure yeah
yeah I don't know about that why don't
we play a song and then we'll give him
the boss girl can we just call him now
come on guys oh okay I can hear that
you're anxious we'll get into it
thank you
Dawn uh uh she's been dating this guy uh
it's been a few months they really like
each other he's silly he's a silly goose
silly goose he's so silly he's ignoring
her yeah now apparently Dawn that's
according that sort of fits the the way
that you guys are you do argue a lot
right
yes that's just you know like sometimes
we
um have like little stacks and stuff
that's just how it is it's not a big
deal and it is a big deal it is a very
big deal do not get into long-term
relationships with people that you
cannot get along with because in your
30s with what she's looking for your
life will become a nightmare once you
say I do and you start popping out
babies and you have a house to deal with
because if you think you can untie the
knot quickly and easily with an
insufferable long-term relationship it's
not quick and easy
I just
you know it's been a couple of days and
I need him to stop being ridiculous no
it is big enough that you have called I
need a radio station to get him to stop
being ridiculous you heard that right
Hold Us for ghosted so we're going to
give him a call now with you listening
you ready to go
yeah that would be great okay let's do
it
hi this is Paul hi Paul it's Adam wild
and Jax from 999 Virgin Radio uh this is
a side note does anybody answer the
phone and be like hi this is Paul
I just hey hello who's this you know
like it's strange isn't it good morning
oh hey what's up hey how you doing
oh I mean I'm pretty good but I don't
know why you're calling me why are you
ignoring your girlfriend
let's get right into it
she would call you
and what would what would you say if we
called you what
that could have been weird
wait yeah well I basically I'm trying to
figure out man like [__] you say she
would call us like what makes you
believe that and what's going on
because she's a bossy woman and she's
probably bossing you around
bossy I didn't get too much of that no
she seemed like she just was on a
mission so so what do you mean bossy
tell us what you mean
she's commanding she is independent she
just tries to get her way all the time
that's kind of hot unless it's in a bad
way so why why don't you like that are
you are you being a little trickster and
ignoring her
oh no no I'm I'm ignoring her because
she's clearly
to me in competition with her sister and
she's just trying to beat her through me
can you so again ticker Below guys if
you don't have the red flag chapter
I mean it's in the book you should have
the book if you don't have the book get
it you can get it from the email list
um he just said she's in competition
this is one of these competitive girls
number four on the red flag list don't
deal with women that compete with you
now he's not saying specifically
competes with him but she's competing
with her sibling which will turn into
competition with you momentarily but pay
attention here give us an example of of
that and why you would be needed for her
to beat her sister
well I've noticed that she's extremely
competitive
she
like her sister became a dentist so she
became an orthodontist
okay she she her sister bought a Jeep
she bought a G-Wagon oh
okay her sister is uh moving in with her
boyfriend
so she's telling me I should move in
with her
now keep in mind they've only dated for
three months here at this point
okay so you think she's just trying to
one-up her sister just with any man
oh oh absolutely because she's trying to
get married her sister
and so all I hear about is getting
married ah yeah yeah yeah we were
talking about baby rabies in the last
one they've been dating for three months
and she's trying to push this guy to
move in immediately and get married
because the next step is going to be
popping out a bunch of babies right
because the timeline's short you know
there's like women haven't expiry date
on their fertility the problem is is
that
it doesn't matter if you tell them when
they're 22 they won't listen
ladies you're most fertile around 21 22
your best chance of having healthy
family healthy children are then don't
put it off but everything in culture and
society today now tells women go out
Chase Excellence get degrees climb the
corporate ladder frame those degrees of
mahogany make sure those little letters
after your name you know implying the
importance of what it is that you do put
off having kids do it later freeze your
eggs you know we've heard the story time
and time and time and time again right
and then they get to the point we're in
their 30s and they see people around
them maybe their sister you know doing
well in life and you know moving in a
certain direction that they want to be
in it's like they will just
like twist your arm to get you to go
wherever it is that it is they want to
go and this guy's doing the absolute
right thing putting some distance
between him and her let's carry on
so she wants you to propose now probably
too
oh okay Paul that's enough
tired of this argument now
and there she goes she jumps in they're
supposed to stay off on the sidelines
and just sort of listen and let the
radio sort of deal with it but she's
like okay Paul that's enough let's let's
stop playing the silly game now
he's on the line yes she is I wouldn't
expect anything less than that
um yeah she is Dawn what's your response
to all this
yeah so he's sticking to the theory
about my sister like about Diane it's
just it's getting really old okay
it's not my fault that you're not ready
for reality you know Lighthouse has
started some point and you can't just
keep being stagnant oh God again
reminder they've only been dating for
three months
you know what we've only been dating for
three months did she tell you that it's
only been three months yeah we we did
get that talking about marriage I
wouldn't call that stagnant I would call
that you know realistic
wow Paul uh Jackson case you don't know
this one over here is a woman
you really like almost had me convinced
that you believe in what you're saying
like Anyway knock it off we can talk
about this later when I come over
knock it off we can talk about this
later when I just slide right back into
your life and come over tonight
and guess what her angle is going to be
when she comes over tonight you guys put
it in the chat I'm not going to say it
live but we'll just let you let you guys
put in the chat right
do not come over I'm serious Dawn I
don't want to continue this with you I
know you're used to getting your way but
I don't want to be part of that I'm done
okay okay okay somebody put their big
boy pants on this party I get it but
like you're just chastising him and
belittling him like the audacity you
want to get married you want this guy to
propose to you and you're treating him
like a child
trying to embarrass me in front of your
two new friends now and sharing all your
secrets but you're only embarrassing
yourself right now
you know you're you're the person that
called them right
okay look I'm not trying to say anything
this isn't my problem good luck Don
I don't think he wants I don't okay
that's pretty much the end of that she
starts ripping into the radio show like
I didn't ask you for advice you heard it
at the intro so we don't need to carry
on with this she's a very she's a very
tough cookie
um again this guy did the right thing
he's obviously got options he doesn't
sound like a beta like the other guy we
dealt with in the previous reel on the
YouTube video uh he basically just said
I'm not dealing with your [__] I'm not
I'm not gonna let myself get pushed
around I'm not playing these games don't
come over you're not gonna like try to
give me some Wicked sex tonight to like
trick me into falling back and all like
this is what the entire strategies that
she's trying to play he knows what's up
and he's like I'm out done
let's let's call it a day he did the
right thing
if you're a lady and you're in your 30s
and you're watching this right now and
you're thinking yourself well why aren't
men growing up why won't they take me
seriously why why
Eddie Murphy stand up look
ladies cool your jets
be feminine
seriously be feminine right like he
doesn't care about your G-Wagon your
orthodontic degree and all those things
he clearly doesn't care there's no guy
in history that's ever looked at a
woman's degree on the wall and been like
oh look at that degree man that's
that's hot look at that
oh yeah that's a good degree dudes don't
do that we look at a woman
and we're like um yeah that's right
we look at Beauty we look at femininity
women are Beauty objects to men they're
sex objects to men they've talked about
this for decades in Evo psych men on the
other hand are success objects to women
so it's a so it's incumbent upon men to
do something with their lives to put a
dent in the universe to be significant
to be influential to lead all of those
things that I talk about in my book and
the other podcasts that I've done for a
long time now
men be men women be women let's stop
trying to blur the line and soften men
and masculize women it's not working
these are the type of scenarios that
come out of you know the all of these
efforts that are that are being made now
and it's just dividing the Sexes and
look guys you know some people say oh
well you know do you hate men or do you
hate women none of those things
none of those things men and women are
better together they you know they
really are if
they are a compliment to each other's
lives I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the
full-length podcast you can find that
over here that clips from if you're new
to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out